Riot's fighting game project L is still
in development but this past Monday we
got the closest look yet at some of the
gameplay systems we can expect to see
when it finally releases whenever that
is it and frankly based on everything
we're seeing is shaping up to be a very
interesting game so even though they
showed off some of these systems there
were plenty of things that were actually
just shown not mentioned so we want to
point those out for you too so whether
you're a die-hard fighting game fan or
you just want to learn more about this
game that's going to have your favorite
League champion it come along as we
explore what we learned from this video
and what we can expect from projectile
in the future
foreign
[Music]
Centigrade it's perfect hoodie weather
that's what I was out in this morning
but you don't have to go without a
hoodie because we've got you covered on
our merch store which I'll drop a link
for in the description below we've got
all sorts of Esports merch including
some pretty dope hoodies you could make
sure you get your daily reminder to
touch grass or you know you could go
with the classic the black Esports
hoodie which I personally love I have
one and I wear it all the time it's just
in a wash right now so again check out
the merch store link is in the
description alright back to the video
okay so first a quick recap project L I
assume that's not going to be the game's
final name is an upcoming fighting game
from Riot games the game was first
teased back at Evo 2019 it looked way
different back then too and now we've
gotten a couple small videos along the
way but this new one kind of blows those
other ones out of the water so we know a
few things about this game for sure it's
going to be free to play feature League
of Legends characters and it's a tag
Fighter game director Sean Rivera
explained in this newest video we were
originally developing project L to be a
1v1 game where two Champions enter and
one emerges Victorious but around two
years ago we made the pivot to a tag
team assist Space Fighter now if you're
not a fighting game fan and if you're
not please stick with me until the end
of the video because I think there are
some important things to talk about if
so then you might not know that a tag
fighter means you build a team of
characters in this game that
specifically means two normally when
you're playing a game like this you can
call in the assist character while
you're controlling your active or Point
character and sometimes they have
multiple options for what kind of attack
they do when they assist you or maybe
you want to switch things up so you can
tag out your active character for the
assist character they swap places now
you're controlling that other character
and if you've played Marvel vs Capcom
you know exactly what I'm talking about
it's also the Jean genre that gave us
one of the hypest plays in the Esports
the happy birthday when a character and
their assist character are caught in the
same combo now the reason I'm explaining
this is because the video that we got
from Riot this past Monday actually
deals a lot with these systems that are
usually so inherent to tag Fighters we
know project L will have Assist attacks
they're calling them assist actions for
now and it looks like Fighters have two
options the normal assist and a charge
input which gives a different attack tag
Fighters often allow you to tag in a new
character during a combo this was of
course a very classic part of Marvel vs
Capcom 3. but Riot showed off a new
system that they are calling handshake
tag which allows you to swap between
your two characters while they are both
on the screen handshake tag lets you
immediately swap between your point and
assist Champions as long as they're both
on screen
when combined with assist actions it
also lets you set up some really
powerful pressure sequences and you can
even use these to extend your combos as
well so it lets you do some pretty cool
stuff even something as simple as
changing which direction your opponent
needs to block can be a major Game
Changer it also seems like the character
you switch away from will finish
whatever they're doing including
follow-up attacks so it actually works
in much the same way as it did in Marvel
vs Capcom infinite it's just that you
probably didn't see much of that game
because it didn't do well unfortunately
it's another tool that players can use
in a head-to-head mental matchup and
while it looks a little confusing at
first I think new players will quickly
get the hang of just switching out for
defensive or offensive reasons another
staple of tag Fighters tends to be long
combos so this game is giving you a way
to stop those and Riot is calling it
Dynamic save at the start of each match
you have access to your dynamic
saveability
Dynamic save lets you call your assist
champion on screen in an attempt to save
your point champion this is another
staple from TAG Fighters just again
given how long combos typically are but
given the wording that Riot use here
that you have it at the beginning of the
match I wonder if maybe there's some way
to get it back okay so there were a few
things that we noticed that weren't
called out specifically in the video so
I want to call those details to your
attention so we can learn a little bit
more about project L before I do that
just big shout out to my co-worker
Danielle Rosen who went over the video
frame by frame and made this analysis
possible on such a short time frame we
just mentioned Dynamic save but there's
a detail in the video that isn't
explicitly pointed out which is that we
see somebody try to use a dynamic save
but it doesn't hit and it actually
punishes that character like the game
does it puts you into like a flip out
State and there's like a red effect as
part of the dynamic save burst be
careful about timing your Dynamics
because it can be countered if you're
being too predictable
the video had sections for movement
offense and defense but in these
sections the narration was more General
design philosophy still we caught some
interesting details that we want to
share with you first is that push block
sometimes called advancing guard is
clearly in the game and in some cases it
was a massive pushback that still let
them punish we don't know exactly how
this will work it has to be an option
with some limits obviously and we have
seen UI elements in previous videos that
looked like you know some kind of meter
or special resource bar so that's likely
what it will cost but we don't know that
for sure yet one thing we don't see in
this video though is a Perry which it
looked like we saw from an Ari in a
previous video so it's not clear if
that's still in there and at 3 45 in the
video you could see Ari do this little
animation that seems to be a dash cancel
and the player uses it to stop their
string and grab the blocking Echo you
catch that here it is again in slow
motion I wonder if this is unique to Ari
because I don't think we've seen this
animation before another thing that this
video did is seemingly confirm that
there will be multiple levels of supers
or maybe multiple gauges that you can
spend on different things that look like
supers or ultimates or whatever because
we've seen multiple different animations
for characters like Ari already
generally the game so far is looking
pretty flat pretty horizontal there is a
section that mentions that super jump is
a movement option it's not clear if we
see that in this video but if we do then
the super jumps aren't that big and
finally some miscellaneous character
stuff before we move on to talk about
the fgc's role in all of this so allowie
we knew she was in the game but we
hadn't really seen any of her kit and
unsurprisingly now that we have it looks
like it's going to focus around
tentacles she has this little launcher
that seems to always spawn a tentacle
and they're definitely going to be
helpful for creating some sneaky setups
and it's pretty cool that you get like a
big bodied character that's focused on
these weird Mix-Ups it doesn't usually
happen that way and I like it that's
some cool flavor we got to see Echo use
jinx's flame Chomper to set up a combo
the little Chompy guy does damage on hit
but then latches on and explodes to help
Echo set up a combo pretty cool Jinx
also has this scary little flip move
that we see a few times so take a look
at this and tell me which side she's
coming down on
it's pretty sneaky as an Akuma player I
approve we also saw one of the drawbacks
to using echo's rewind specifically
attacking out of the rewind is that it
looks like the recovery animation always
has him sort of like rev the Z drive so
you get a little bit of a longer
recovery at 4 20 in the video nice uh
there is a different kind of tag that
isn't mentioned by the developers it
appears to be a tag launcher and of
course we saw this in another game that
wasn't very successful Street Fighter
cross Tekken as an aside Danielle and I
were joking that if this game could
succeed it would exercise the Damned
ghosts of both sfxt and mvci since both
these games didn't really do that well
but they had some great ideas and it
looks like there might be a little bit
of that DNA in Project L and I guess
that's the last thing I want to talk
about today whether this game can
succeed we've mentioned this in other
videos about projectile but with both
Tom and Tony cannon on board they've got
a great Foundation like these are two
Evo co-founders and they have resumes in
the space so that's a great start but we
also learned from path to flip on
Twitter that Riot is teaching the
development team internally about what
makes fighting games so great like they
literally have someone teaching them
about the genre remember they've hired
some veterans but Wright has never
actually made a fighting game before and
this is so cool so incredible to see in
the video they also did something that I
found surprising they told potential
players to find their local fighting
game scene and get involved finally for
those of you out there looking to get
into fighting games for the first time
try finding a local scene in your area
as a reminder this game is not out yet
and it does not seem like it will be out
anytime soon so what does this mean
hopefully it means that Riot isn't a
aiming to create some kind of fighting
game LCS or something but instead
they're going to support this game from
the Grassroots starting point and then
see where it goes from there you know
nurture it instead of nationalize it I
guess yeah they also did something else
they asked fgc veterans to drop some
helpful links in the chat fgc folks help
the new folks out by sharing your links
in the comments the way that Tom Cannon
makes us request in a video is so matter
of fact so obvious as if he knows for
certain that there's no way that anyone
would refuse to do that like in some
communities when you haven't even made a
game yet I feel like asking for
something like this could be met with
some amount of derision or frustration
or hostility but fighting games are
different and they've had to be because
at the end of the day they've needed new
people since basically bereft so
fighting games had to be accommodating
and it seems like Riot and the Canon
Brothers obviously understand that and
at least based on what's been shown
there seems to be a lot of excitement
and a lot of Goodwill in the fighting
game Community for one of the biggest
companies to enter the space in a long
time so we're gonna keep waiting on info
for project well I just really hope we
don't have to wait too much longer
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this hit the sub button and
ring the notification Bell for Unique
bite-sized videos you won't find
anywhere else hit us up on our Twitter
Instagram Facebook and tick tock